how's it going bro my name is Rita back
welcome back to some more crying out
fear let's pick up these fuses and head
to the other side it means you have to
say goodbye to dear old friend I'm sorry
I'm sorry my Tom we have something
special I love you but I need a fuse to
progress all right I think someone said
that we will get the m16 sooner or later
again so I'm 16 and my tongue I salute
you you are fine
soldiers like it says no entry badass
[ __ ] I don't care
cannon nerd where'd are you doing here
you were back in the militia one second
ago okay so if my memory is correct that
means we have to go to the barber king
and ask for advice
all hail your BBQing where should we go
I don't freakin remember I think it's
summer here Thank You BBQing for nothing
tells me nothing
Aaron it wait I'm too lazy oh whoa
Emma I need that [ __ ] yes it's over here
I think baby boom ba-ba-boom ba-ba
ba-ba-ba pip ah ah sorry I don't know
what that was holy Sh Kruger that's a
lot of no ladder things alright let's go
so quiet now I like I like cling : hi
how am i walking with the legs when I
don't hear one it make whatever let's
not complain let's do a quick save there
you know I don't really see by quick
seminar so it's kind of difficult but
alright where are we here we are there
we are again in the yellow door of
yellowness I don't know what that was
but it is
I already oh wait I have the
sledgehammer why don't you tell me
Sony Ericsson or sledgehammer I think
sledgehammer is the thing I think it's
right here stupid fired thing that
doesn't even look like a fire thing Oh
what did I do
all right I hope this is the right way
no entry hahaha
go ahead anyway oh it's here lovely
alright let's loot for ammo and stuff
remember boys and girls aids at cent
that's why I shouldn't use the Serene's
that's everywhere by the way like if you
see a serene it's like if you see
something it's pence I swear like it's
not serene I'll show an example I want
my I'm not gonna give you York's fate
stupid briefcase it's my fate my knight
alia alright here's for example that's a
[ __ ] pen it's not a serene remember
aids all right oh yeah yeah what am i
doing I'm so stupid sorry
lamp keep doing your swag alright we
need the fuses over here I think yes all
right I quit I quit that [ __ ] punch you
that's what you get for being so stupid
alright your Joe open there we go quick
psych Hey
so now we will ride fashio that sounds
really disturbing if you're Swedish but
it's okay oh my god let's watch this
Thompson's calendar what are you doing
in the background
who's driving anyway I love her as soon
as we just open the game our jammer
let's not question life it's not really
life but whatever
move back to the Train
yes
I was just about to say that it looks
like a fool just a few seconds ago
oh yeah the game started well I we were
sitting on the [ __ ] I'm not good
trying to kill me since I mean what it's
actually happening to get to get who is
maja me
the rivers mom oh it's all expenses yeah
it's a lot of crazy [ __ ]
what do you mean police bill is
everywhere
yeah I guess but Feliz build-up and I'm
just
mr. bubbly mentum god seriously
that's a good question
something else
I have a doctor day and Sophie's not
Sophie Noah loves fluffy it doesn't even
care about her anymore
I want this gas facts about us just not
real good question
sexually just
marry
it's actually
Oh answers
is he going home are we going home
whoa what was that sophie was that you
can i die without you
Candida oh no oh anything about the
container all right I'm gonna teach
these containers lesson
bring it can either bring it I will get
you your feet if it's the last thing
I'll do all right what am I going anyway
here no all right here we go all right
oh whoa whoa whoa what the hell is that
whoa whoa whoa eat it there you go right
in your face
polish it - is freaking I think I need
to change the gum all right whoa back up
I have a VP don't shoot me boy oh
they're [ __ ] everywhere eat it there
you go
rageh Bosh all right
what are we doing here give mr. Reed's
anywhere place
well mode god I have so much fun haha
what well mother they call some fun it's
a suicide kill yourself like [ __ ] or
something had another bark give your dog
a better nor longer life and calm
and proud of all happiness all right
listen that fantastic let's keep going
isn't it a fan trucker that I'm Swedish
and can translate to be whoa oh no oh no
Sony Ericsson I need you by exam hello
penny
I'm here for you okay fine stop being
such an attention [ __ ] mm yes you came
back to me I love you but now it's dark
I don't like that I like this
it's kind of cool doc I mean that trains
swimmer's mom hiding here somewhere
it's proceed fine I suppose
hello I untrust these windows afraid of
masters their record whoa handicaps oh
no no you're not handicaps are you back
up your toe I'm looking at you he's like
[ __ ] me judge me I dare you oh oh it's a
dance up it's a [ __ ] dance up Oh
guess who's to dance precedent come here
come here all right queer son ha man
sledgehammer knees in your face whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey cover hey
cover switch to the VP VP switching
coach that would show oh no no no no I
have to reload [ __ ] look at my health
now
this is a no suck huh okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay
okay men 16 [ __ ] shoot like a
boss shoot like a boss shoot like a bow
oh oh go home to Reubens mom and suck on
your titties that's what you get your
little battle [ __ ] all right let's
keep going ass but I need should reload
I know it was your Emma but I wanted
reloaded
don't judge me all right what is this
place I don't trust the windows boom Oh
double not double oh [ __ ] I don't have a
lot of health they shook period right in
my face all right
don't double me I'm TT me back
BAM I kill your brother now give up get
me all the Oh No [ __ ]
he had a vengeance I kill your brother I
kill him there you go there you go there
you go that's what you get well no more
no more no more no more no more
how many [ __ ] siblings can you have
alright there we go there we go choke
back so close so close look at my health
this is not funny
hate it double eat it Oh No ah okay I
think I need a head shot him or
something ah we got the VP let's go with
the VP actually let's reload
yes Sansom oh yes
Sansa wait what the hell is this lamp
whoa laughs are you the thief of the
foot
I knew it laughs you can't steal beats I
told you so many times don't steal face
this is your punishment I slap you
whomps and twice but remember it's only
because I love you and I want you to
change all right
DM TV or audio let mama take it
all right lamp I'm sorry don't cry
laughs sigh you can't keep the foot
stupid lamb doesn't realize all right so
let's go back and deliver the foot to
the suitcase I guess [ __ ] lamps are
so crazy
handicaps
all right I'm probably handicapped
considering my health right now I'm just
saying holy shooter this is I don't know
it's really cool mom I can't believe
it's made out a halflife like at that
- I actually ridden one of these tramps
I'm from Gothenburg by the way but I
remember these trams I went there a
couple day years ago so it's kind of
creepy I I don't know what's gonna
happen next time I go on the room is mom
might show up or something all right
let's keep going I suppose
whoa oh oh what the hell was that
no no I didn't shoot the first ones oh
no this is the problem they say ah no I
have the foot all right
oh no let's reload all right this is a
problem we get my help
ha ha ha all right come on come on bring
it where are they where are they where
are they
you're why did I just run so so bad
I know I would have to pay for this
sooner or later oh oh oh I am in deep
[ __ ] [ __ ] here I am in deep [ __ ]
literal and early say cover the cover
all right that's it's not cheat or
anything
ha ha what soon as I rise my head up
I can't even see them there we go
alright [ __ ] let's not cheat them
Jessica [ __ ] four shots Holly shooter
ah son of a penis
oh I got your [ __ ] I doubt your [ __ ] bro
that all you got bro come at me oh [ __ ]
yes you got a lot of [ __ ] ah give me the
VP the vp does a job well like me there
you go a little [ __ ] alright there we
go now we can finally deliver them
what am I doing here Chemical alright
never go
hey hey hey hey all right
I have your foot I don't know why you
want it but here it is almighty
briefcase what happened now oh no oh no
this is what you get when you deliver
feet to briefcases I guess
Oh No Basia Oh No
Pasha no no no no no don't kill yourself
us outfit oh [ __ ] yeah suicide dead okay
[ __ ] look back there's [ __ ] in my bag
whoa whoa what - help chapter 6 all
right
I think it's about time we ended here I
can favorite if you enjoyed subscribe to
become a bro today and I'll see you next
episode it's a good eat your leg a just
God ah son of a [ __ ] right in my ah
you're stuck to me a little [ __ ] now yo
it fighter
ah son of AB sir